a new medical mystery affecting US
diplomatic workers this time in China is
deepening the US Embassy in Beijing is
warning Americans there to watch out for
unexplained illnesses several workers at
us consulates in China have been
evacuated after complaining of hearing
odd sounds then becoming ill CBS news
radio Steve Dorsey was the first to
report on a similar group of ailments in
Cuba he's outside the Chinese Embassy in
Washington
Steve good morning good morning
overnight in another Health Alert the US
Embassy in China urged Americans with
any unexplained physical symptoms to get
medical help amid new concerns this
mysterious case could be worse than
first reported Diplomatic Security
Officer Mark Lindsay is one of the
latest Americans evacuated from the US
consulate in Guangzhou China he's back
in the US for treatment after he says he
was injured after hearing odd sounds in
a statement to CBS News he says the
ordeal is stressful for my family
obviously the State Department is
concerned about health and safety of its
diplomats so we're trying to work
through it in a similar case last year
24 government employees and spouses at
the US Embassy in Cuba complained of
headaches ear pain sleep impairment and
cognitive problems after saying they
also heard strange sounds the u.s.
retaliated by expelling Cuban diplomats
on Tuesday Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo set up a medical Task Force to
seek answers to the mysterious ailments
he addressed Congress last month after
the latest case in China was first
reported we have medical teams that are
moving to be on the ground there we are
we are working to figure out what took
place we've asked the Chinese for their
assistance in doing that but on Thursday
a Chinese foreign ministry spokesperson
said China conducted a thorough
investigation and found nothing
David rank is the former deputy chief of
mission at the US Embassy to China
implication or evidence that this was a
state organized activity would have a
much bigger impact on on our relations
mark Lindsay tells me he'll soon begin
treatment at the University of
Pennsylvania he's also calling on
several top state Department officials
to resign accusing them of a cover-up
Alix Steve thank you